Senate Leader Mitch McConnell made
history today correspondent Peter Doocy
tells us how Mitch McConnell became
Senate Republican leader 11 years five
months and 10 days ago and now he's had
the top spot a day longer than former
Senator Bob Dole making him the longest
tenured GOP leader ever he understands
the Senate better than anybody else here
former senator Trent Lott had a job for
five years I think it was a toughest
leadership job political job in the city
McConnell says he plays the long game
his majorities have passed tax cuts but
failed to repeal Obamacare and in 2010
he took heat for outlining a different
priority our top political priority over
the next two years should be to deny
President Obama a second term six years
later when outgoing President Obama
nominated Merrick garland to the Supreme
Court
McConnell declined to consider him until
after the election American people need
to weigh in and decide who's gonna make
this decision
Democrats criticized McConnell for
breaking tradition we're setting an
incredibly dangerous precedent hi Neal M
for such you solemnly swear
but McConnell waited and later helped
confirm Neal gorsek he's reasonably able
to control his people that in of itself
is something to be credited with he's
also the rare Republican who dares to
share laughs in public with his
Democratic counterpart he plays his
cards very close to his chest but he'll
just sit there and listen and listen and
listen
but sometimes Republicans break ranks
like senator Ted Cruz who once called
McConnell out about the export-import
bank I cannot believe he would tell a
flat-out lie there are also Republican
candidates who try to capitalize on anti
McConnell sentiment one of my goals as
US senator will be to
cocaine Mitch in DC there's not much of
an appetite to remove the Republican
leader he's been right so many times so
it builds confidence among these
colleagues but on this the day that
McConnell finally broke the record his
own members aren't listening to him
multiple Republican senators have told
me that today at lunch McConnell
implored Republicans to stop blocking
Republican amendments and multiple
Republican senators proceeded to leave
lunch and block each other's amendments
Chris Peter Doocy on Capitol Hill Peter
thank you